- [Interviewer] Okay! Nubiana.
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Nubiana.
Where'd you grow up?
Where are you from?
- I'm from Milwaukee, Wisconsin
- [Interviewer] Milwaukee. And you grew up
with both parents or one
parent, or how'd you grow up?
- Mmmmm. Both parents kind of. Like
I had a stepdad and
then, well two stepdads
I didn't really meet my
real dad until I was 15.
So I guess you could say I
have, like I said stepdad.
[Interviewer] Yeah. And
how old are you now?
- I'm about to be 19 in five days.
- [Interviewer] You're 18 going to be 19?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Got it. And
how was your childhood at home?
- It was okay. Like what
do you mean? Like...
- [Interviewer] Well, I mean, like, were
there any issues, problems,
how'd you get along
with your stepdad? Stuff like that.
- I mean, we got along pretty well.
I know they always had my
best interests at heart.
My mom, it was, it was
just tough because like
when I turned, I was
nine years old, my mom
she got turned out to Sherm, you know and
[Interviewer] PCP?
- Right PCP. And, you
know, she...her mind.
She just wasn't really
aware of what was going on.
You know what I'm saying?
As far as like her children?
[Interviewer] Yeah. PCP
makes you lose your mind.
Exactly. So at a young age,
like me and my mom, our
our relationship was kinda
off, you know, but my stepdads
they weren't really there like that.
They, one of my stepdad's
he was in and out of jail,
you know? So it was, you can basically
say I was raised by my mother.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- But, and then when I
was 13, maybe? Yes, 13.
I was taken away from my mom and put
in CPS custody because she
had got so high off Sherm,
like, she kinda like blacked
out and yeah, why I went
to my auntie's and things
really didn't go well
there because like I had
like people trying to
sexually abuse me there
and stuff like that.
So then it was weird because I was so fast
at the time, you know, like me
transitioning to a teenager?
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- I didn't really understand
what my auntie was like
trying to keep me away from
like boys and stuff like that?
And so I got pregnant and then I,
And then I ended up
getting an abortion sadly.
like I've acknowledged,
a mistake you know but...
- [Interviewer] How young were
you when you got pregnant?
- 14.
- [Interviewer] 14?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And the, and the, the,
at your aunt's house the people that were
trying to molest you were
her...her husband or...?
- Her son.
- [Interviewer] Her older son?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Oh.
- So, um...
- [Interviewer] it's a rough childhood.
- Right. So that led me to like run away
and then I had to leave my twin sister.
And so that was kind of
sad. It took a toll on me
because I didn't want to leave her
but at the same time it was like
was I going to go back and be abused
and then hope like, you
know what I'm saying?
Something bad happened to my child.
So it was just like,
I don't want anything.
Like, I don't want no type
of responsibility of that.
You know what I'm saying?
Cause I wouldn't know
how to live with myself
if something happened
to my child on my watch or,
you know, under my care.
So it was just like, so then I ran away
and I went home to my
grandmother, Lucy, she's like 96.
She's still living. That's a good thing.
But I stayed with her
for about like six months
- [Interviewer] And this
is all in Wisconsin?
- This is in St. Louis. I
actually went to St. Louis. Yes.
- [Interviewer] Okay, so you went from
Wisconsin to St. Louis..
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Missouri.
- Yeah. And I went with my grandma
and I stayed with her for a while.
Like kinda like looked
after her and stuff.
And then I went and my
sister she picked me up
and I stayed with my sister for awhile and
helping her out and things like that.
And then I got myself back in school.
My sister put me through
school because you know
with me leaving and stuff like that.
- [Interviewer] Did
you finish high school?
- Yes. I'm actually in college right now.
- [Interviewer] Oh you are?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Good for you!
- But it's just kinda
hard to like, to like,
you know maintain because the kind of
work field that I'm in, you know?
- [Interviewer] Yes. And how long
you been working as a stripper?
- Well...
- [Interviewer] When did you
start? Because you're young.
- I actually started like the day I...
- [Interviewer] How does an 18 year old
work in the strip club? Don't you have
to be 20, don't you have to be 21?
- No, well in some, you do.
I mean, you know that all the
rules don't apply to me.
You know what I'm saying?
- [Interviewer] You
figure out ways around it?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- But my first job I worked
at Blue Moon's in Arizona
like on 32nd and Van, you
know what I'm talking about?
- [Interviewer] I don't know.
- Oh. Well it's kinda
like Scottsdale area?
- [Interviewer] Okay.
- Phoenix. But...
- [Interviewer] That's a strip club?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Got it.
- It's called Blue
Moon's Gentleman's Club.
It was just really nice,
you know, discreet.
I started working there because
I quit my job at Red Lobster you know,
it was like, wasn't making enough money.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
- And then I felt unappreciated.
Like I was devalued, you know?
So I was just like, you know
what? Since I'm already serving
and acting like, you know what I'm saying?
Like they already treating
me like a peasant anyway,
like give me one dollar. Some
people left me two cents.
Like what the, what the
freak am I going to do
with two cents, you know? How're
you going to pay your base,
How're you going to pay
your bills with that?
I was talking with my friend and she was
basically saying like, "Oh!
You got a banging body.
Like you should, you
should come work with me.
And they're auditioning on Sunday".
So I was just like, at first I was like,
No way! My family's gonna see me.
You know what I'm saying?
Because even though my mom
was like doing drugs and
stuff like that, she was like
my mom was a registered nurse before
she did all... You know what I'm saying?
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
Like, she got turned
out to things like that.
Like, it can happen to
anybody, but like, like
you know, my family, they
still they're still humans,
you know. They're not
everybody's not a drug addict
and nothing like that. So
it was just like, Oh my God
they're going to see me naked.
Or what if they what if they find out?
And it was just like, once I did it
it was like, oh, it's like,
I got my own life to live.
You know? So, I went to the audition
and the lady Kendra, she liked me.
She was like, "You're cute".
She was like, "But when
you're up there", cause like
I guess it's a thing that
everybody does there.
They move so fast when you're
on the p.... (laughter)
they moved so fast. And she told me
because I'm black, I have
to move slower, you know?
Like, so it was kinda adjustments
in the industry as well.
Like, you know be me,
being the skin complexion
that I am, you know? Like it's not easy
for every door to be open to me, you know?
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- So it's just like,
like, it was like all,
"Okay. I'm in the strip
club. Hopefully I make it.
I'm going to make it about 5,000.
Hopefully I'm going to
make this, this" you know?
But grass is not always greener
on the other side, you know
it has its cons and pros to it as well.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- You know? Like safety hazards and stuff.
Like my safety is number one, you know.
Before, it was like I
used to walk around like,
like all green wasn't
goin' to do nothin' to me.
Until I started working up in the club,
you know, and things started happening.
But, as far as me being a stripper? Hmmm.
- [Interviewer] You
worked in other clubs too?
- Yes. Well, like under the table
kinda, you know what I'm saying?
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- Yeah. So.
- [Interviewer] So, I mean, when you
when you're working as a stripper
sometimes the guys want extra favors?
- (laughter)
- [Interviewer] And is that can
you make extra money doing that?
- Oh no! Actually you can, I've seen
other girls do it but I've never done it.
- [Interviewer] You don't do it?
- No!
- [Interviewer] Okay. And how
much do you make in a night?
- Well, it all depends.
Cause you know, every
one night you can walk out with five Bens,
the next night you walk out
with three dollars, you know?
So it just all depends. You
know, it's like, it's good.
It has good days and its bad days but
I sell out some shows.
So I guess all I can say
I make like 'bout like five,
six hundred on like a bad day.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
But on a good day, probably like a
thousand or two, you know?
- [Interviewer] Right.
It all depends on who's in,
how slow it is. You get me?
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- But.
- [Interviewer] And the hours
are typically like you're
you're getting off at work
- Well...
- [Interviewer] at like
four in the morning,
or something like that, right?
- Right. Right.
I was about to say, hourly? I don't
get paid hourly. It's
like workin' a contract.
- [Interviewer] No. I said hours.
You start late and you finish late.
- Yes. Well basically come
in from like nine to four.
- [Interviewer] Yeah. And that
makes it hard to go to school.
- Right. So it's like, I'm, I'm like
sleep deprived, you know? I'm very,
I can't really focus like that.
so that's why I said it's
kinda hard to go to school
go to college and then
maintain my stripper.
And then also like, like
people, they like, like I have
I've seen guys that come to the club
and they be at my school.
So it's like it's
(laughter) It's so weird!
Like I don't unders..., like,
I don't know. It's weird.
Like, so it's like, my life
is so public. You get me?
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- So it's not like it's
so discreet anymore.
So that's where I just like
kicked my emotions, you know
turned that switch off.
Like, you know what?
I don't care who knows what I'm doing.
You know, I got to put food in my mouth.
You know what I'm saying?
So I was just like that.
- [Interviewer] And what did, what
are your plans for the future?
Where're you going to go from here?
- Well, I'm actually in cl...like
I'm studying medical right
now. Like I'm in school, like PCT it's
Patient Care Technician.
So basically like,
I'm going to be able to
like, like draw blood, CPR
and stuff, just stuff like that.
And then they're going to throw
in like a CNA course stuff.
You know what I'm talking about?
Like, so I'll be CNA registered.
So before you become a
registered nurse, you have to
have your CNA. You have
to be CNA certified.
So that's what I'm trying to get.
I'm in school right now
to be CNA certified.
And then after that I go
for registered nursing.
It all depends. Like, I'm
just, I'm like I'm young.
So I'm only 18. I'm so confused.
Like how can you be a stripper
and then be a nurse?
But then you know what?
I've heard people, you know, I heard
a lot of testimony, so
never say never, but.
- [Interviewer] Excellent.
Well, darlin' thank you so much
for talking to me and good luck with
whatever you end up doing.
- Thank you!
- [Interviewer] And what
you're doing currently.
- You have a wonderful day.
- [Interviewer] All right. Thank you.